this day in history what a great day I
remember I was just a wee little lad on
this day in history in 1998 but Bill
Clinton was impeached for lying under
oath to a federal grand jury and
obstructing justice let's roll the clip
House Resolution 6-1 for resolved that
mr. Hyde mr. Sensenbrenner mr. McCollum
mr. gikas mr. Kennedy mr. buuder mr.
Bryant mr. Chabot mr. Barr mr.
Hutchinson mr. kanin mr. Rogan and mr.
Graham our appointed managers to conduct
the impeachment trial against William
Jefferson Clinton on this vote the yeas
are 228 the nays are 206 Article one is
adopted
sad sad for bill now why was he
impeached I did not have sexual
relations with that woman these
allegations are false but then about
five minutes later he admitted this
indeed I did have a relationship with
Miss Lewinsky that was not appropriate
in fact it was wrong it constituted a
critical lapse in judgment and a
personal failure on my part for which I
am solely and completely responsible I
misled people including even my wife
[Music]
[Applause]
that was quite a change now how could
Bill Clinton make both of those
statements with a straight face it's
because he's also the guy who said this
no sex of any kind any manner born with
the president what utterly false me it
depends upon what the meaning of the
word is it depends on what the meaning
of the word is unbelievable watch that
when he's referring to is when he told
his aides there's nothing going on with
Monica Lewinsky now he was following the
classic mob advice of deny till you die
so Bubba explained himself he said if is
means is and never has been that is not
that is one thing if it means there is
none that was a completely true
statement now if someone had asked me on
that day are you having any kind of
sexual relations with Miss Lewinsky that
is asked me a question in the present
tense I would have said no and it would
have been completely true ah completely
completely true he says completely true
Slick Willy Clinton so he got impeached
Clinton was the second president in
American history to be impeached for
charges were considered there was
perjury obstruction of justice a second
perjury and abuse of power the first two
passed the house decided not to pursue
the second two so he lied about a year
and a half long sexual affair with
Monica Lewinsky a 21 year old intern who
when he was 49 and 50 years old so
Democrats tried to play it off as some
little fling Clinton's associates and
his wife and campaign managers smeared
the women as bimbos and trailer trash
but remember this isn't some fling we're
talking about the president of United
States and his employee who was 28 years
younger certainly young enough to be his
daughter consider for a moment the
performed anger right now that we're
seeing from Democrats at Roger Ailes
Bill O'Reilly even Matt Lauer Charlie
Rose on and on and on what they did
doesn't hold a candle to what Bill
Clinton did all of those guys doesn't
hold a candle to what Bill Clinton did
among the more lurid findings of the
investigation against him or Bill
Clinton's
creative use of a cigar on the lowest
level staff member in his employ
sometimes a cigar is just a cigar but
not for Bill Clinton